the man who's calling tonight's game
all-star game on Fox with Joe Buck the
Baseball Hall of Famer who I believe if
I had to take a guess
was in the bullpen at the time he's John
Smoltz how are you John I'm doing good
the Bo Jackson didn't give me what I
wanted because one out runners on 1st
and 3rd after watching him do what he
did against Rick Russell and the whole
debacle I was supposed to pitch the 3rd
inning so I wanted to go to the bullpen
none of the veteran guys being a rookie
that I was I had no idea how to get to
the bullpen in a tie
none of the rookies would take me down
there they said let's just watch the
first inning that won't take you down in
the second great so second comes and
Rick's having a hard time and Tommy
Lasorda gives to the phone he says gets
all T up and I'm 10 feet from my manager
and he looked at me says what are you
doing I don't like I don't know how to
get down there he goes how many pitches
will it take you to get ready I said
seven and so I get down there and time
to throw 7 warmup pitches I get in my
first almost are game forget everything
everybody told me before I left I what
not to do hmm I get to a first and third
situation bo Jackson's up and it's a
one-two count and I'm thinking okay how
do I get this guy to hit the ball on the
ground so I get out of this in a tie
game routine ground ball hopper to Ozzie
Smith to Ryan Sandberg throw to first
safe beat it out I get the loss and my
personal star game bo Jackson historic
power plus combination of speed so yeah
he might have given America what so
that's your introduction to the all-star
game and an eventual eighth all-star
game appearance Hall of Fame career that
was the way you started your all-star
career at the way it started and timing
is everything of course and I've given
up two runs in my all-star appearances
and I have two losses come on are you
serious yep games that I entered I gave
up a home run to Miguel Tejada in a
all places my hometown Tiger Stadium
well not the old Tigers days sure the
new one and yeah that was uh I was
supposed to close the game if that year
Tony LaRussa was the manager and because
they wanted guys who were quicker to
home plate to help out Mike Piazza
behind the plate because he said
everybody will steal in this game if we
don't have our fastest time pitchers
early in the game so even though we want
you to close the game we want you to
pitch as early as you can so that we can
control the running game
well I controlled the running game but I
didn't control the ball that went out of
the park at about 430 B no kidding and I
think was that your last all-star game
205 might have been let's see I didn't I
qualified later for San Francisco but I
had hurt myself and had to fly all the
way back and went on the DL and and it
wasn't able to make it back for just for
the introductions but I couldn't pitch
yeah you made it so yeah as you pointed
out but so alright John Smoltz here in
the Richardson let's talk about the good
times then the the 96 game you started
in one you won that was that was in
Philly right John I would that was a lot
of fun yeah I got to start through two
innings it was having a magical year of
course that finish dollar for the
magical year I'm wanting to say on but
but that was a lot of fun and you know
you're in an all-star game you want to
obviously compete do well for your team
do all for that league there's so many
things that happen in a short period of
time that you know it is pretty
incredible no matter if you go to Warren
or 15 like some of these guys have done
but but it is it's I've said I said this
earlier is that you know when you're
lucky you just kind of crawl in your
locker and you just sit there and you
just hope okay this was back then
because you're filled with lockers that
guys are we're talking teens they've
been two teens all-star game they're
routinely going there and you're just
checking in for your first time you're
going representative you just keep quiet
then your second and third you go okay I
belong here and I can I feel like I can
compete with some of these guys today's
rookies and young players are not only
feeling like they belong there impactful
and there's no intimidation they
Gamze younger the game's dynamic with
young talent so it's really changed that
the culture has changed in how they
walked in is it like I know I'm a bad
dude and everyone else knows I'm a bad
dude and I don't have to really feel
like I have to sit back and you know
there's still some off actor but they've
contributed at such a level that it's
really different and how the all-star
games twenty thirty years ago compared
to today well I'll tell you what I know
he's not playing tonight but Ladd jr.
certainly looked pretty damn comfortable
last night John
that was amazing he did he did and it
was amazing I've never seen quite like
that you know some people can say they
all the homerun competition is XYZ to
them or XYZ tonight last night was one
of those rare moments where not only was
it introduced that a million dollars
gets goes to the winner it was an epic
battle between a young up-and-coming
superstar already and John Peterson who
just to everyone who tuned in to bat one
single battle it was epic I mean I no
other way to say it I was I found myself
going you got to be kidding me that's
right whether there was one dollar or no
dollars put on the winners so
unfortunately it cost either one of
those a chance to win that's the bad
part because it was it just they were
exhausted yeah toast I mean you can't
even imagine but the but this the just
the the way that Peterson gave everybody
in a little bit of hope that he could
dig out of the what that 29 home run
deficit as he stepped right and the fact
that he the fact that he did in fact
give people hope and then delivered by
tying with no time left leading to two
different swing-offs that really was I I
mean you're right epic is the perfect
word for John that was amazing he
reminded me a little bit of and I
believe in Miami went judge was had to
overcome his and he made it look like
ridiculously stupid he went on a run
that we just haven't seen so last night
was pretty cool John Smoltz here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get to the I guess
topic du jour and that's courtesy of
Justin Verlander
and Verlander saying that he believes
the balls are juiced in actual major
league competition this year would you
would you agree with that assessment
John I would agree I listen I I think I
always say is I'm going to err on the
side of the expert who has in whatever
their field is like a baseball and a
hand of a third baseman is not the same
as the hand of a pitcher right so you
could blindfold me put ten different
baseball's in my hand and I could tell
you exactly everything you need to know
about them because I've had over two
million in my hand so when the ball
feels different as a pitcher you tell
exactly you've got the ball it's the
same thing as a photographer I'm gonna
trust a photographer the my own eyes on
what is a better shoot or a better
picture making or a producer and they're
all the different fields that they've
done it long enough so how much of its
intentional I can't even come comprehend
but I would say this percentage-wise the
ball's different the commissioners even
echoed that that's different there's
something different they're trying to
figure out why the ball is going farther
they're less drag and why the leather is
is tighter than it maybe has been in the
past but also philosophically the game
has changed so you're going to get more
homeruns whether the ball was juice or
not is just the style of baseball it's
the way that they're rewarding their
players it's a system the players are
growing up in so their their idea of
going to the plate and trying to go the
other way get a single is probably the
farthest thing for most people's minds
with the exception of Jeff mr. McNeill
and I think that in and of itself has a
percentage bump but it's the distances
that are getting people a little bit
more concern to think that the ball is
traveling farther and staying in the air
longer so that combination is creating a
buzz where okay the pendulum has swung
pretty far where does the pendulum come
back where do we find the happy medium
because in the NBA they're shooting a
ton of three-pointers you could say the
three-point shot there's more
three-pointers than ever before but the
reason is because they're more it's not
necessarily there's greater shooters
although there are some it's just that
they're shooting more and so the style
of baseball is also creating to that
well it's interesting you bring that up
John because a
you're right with the NBA it's just that
everybody it's now analytically and also
coached not just at the professional
level but for anybody coming up the
ranks shoot threes you they'd rather you
shoot the three then the mid-range
jumper or if you are in deep two-point
range take a step back because you might
as well get that extra point by
attempting it seems the same thing is
being brought to bear in baseball by
swing harder just swing harder swing
over tonight want to beat the shift
swing over it because exit velocity
matters swing harder it's it does appear
to be a similar situation John would you
would you think it does and in the kind
of the the reverse example would be as
if they made the basketball smaller you
would think this shot being made are
going to be easier in basketball right
so if you shooting more threes it's
easier to make them if the ball smaller
well if the ball is harder and the ball
travels farther then it's easier to lift
the ball in the air keep it in the air
longer and therefore that's where the
confusions coming in with the ball
either being juiced or the fact that
it's going you know distances we haven't
seen in a long time
but guys are stronger guys are swinging
the bat at an alarming Pat speed that I
just can't imagine is sustainable over a
10-year period but we're gonna find out
if this style of baseball if the
pendulum swings back analytically within
organizations that say okay we all have
these same information we're all doing
the same thing what's the advantage then
there's not much let's go back let's
make some changes let's start to create
some issues and stress on the base path
I believe whether through rule changes
or just team zigging when everyone
zagging eventually it'll come back and
the fundamentals of baseball will be
more integrated than this just monster
baseball where guys are bigger stronger
faster and they just hit the ball all
over the place because there's still an
element that I as a broadcaster and a
fan of the game and love the game I
still want to see these guys play a long
time now if this formula allows them to
play a long time it certainly would have
to buck the
current trend that's going on right now
with the injury rate that which to get
to this level you have to be this kind
of trained machine to hit the ball and
be strong enough and therefore you bring
in the risk of a lot of injuries and
therefore the pitchers who throw the
ball 97 98 99 miles an hour that's
harder to sustain so that's what I'm
looking to see how that tracks when you
have a great example in tonight's
starting lineup the pitchers that are
going for the American and National
League a great example of the polar
opposites of pitchers reuse dominated
this year without 95 a burr Lander has
dominated with the ability to throw 95
well up into his years cruise control
and his ability to just transform time
and look like he could pitched at least
45 well I mean in a couple minutes I
left have left you with you here John
Smoltz a couple more things that
Verlander said that that that certainly
one thing that has already disturbed the
commissioner Rob Manfred who said this
morning just moments ago saying quote
there is no desire on part of ownership
to increase the number of homers in the
game vehemently denying what Verlander
saying that it's a hundred percent the
league is purposefully implemented
juiced baseball's to increase offense do
you think baseball has done something
like that no that's what I don't know
you know how you I mean you can know as
a pitcher that something's not right but
then I don't know if you could go as far
as to say that you feel like it's
intentional again all the things we
discover are going to be thrown in the
Hat and what percentage that comes out
Manufacturing a baseball from what I
believe what I understand is not done
just simply by one company there's
multiple facets and handmade and the
Turk that the technology may have
allowed incidental things to happen that
weren't intended and by a new way of
making the baseball so it's in every
other sport it's in golf I mean at some
point the ball technology and just how
far everybody's hit were enamored with
it we love it golfers they've you know
baseball in college basketball the
different things that you try
to reel back in it'll be interesting to
see what comes out of the information
that they're trying to look for to see
why the baseball's are going you know
not to mention the air and sure all the
things that we deal with today well I
got one more minute left if you can bet
best you can tell
Verlander told ESPN I hate the way I
feel out there no matter who's the
batter I feel like I'm constantly
walking a tightrope on is that effective
pitcher John well it affects your
mentality of how you pitch and in looks
this is a guy that when the baseball
gets to the highest point pressure he'll
pitch differently anyways postseason
he's dominated because he can't in a
regular season game I said the same
thing I I gave up a lot of home runs
that probably would never give up in a
postseason because you're gonna take
more chances with a 3-1 to 1 fastball
and what I think he's saying is you
can't take those chances anymore
the main eighth and ninth hole hitter
can take you the other way based on the
distance the ball is traveling and the
way the parks are made so I understand
in theory what he's saying because as a
pitcher you don't want to be embarrassed
you want to get it done just like a
hitter doesn't want to get embarrassed
he wants to get it done so he's a
world-class picture of this adjusted at
every level and he will continue to
adjust no matter what the baseball is or
isn't because he has that capability and
I think the game the athletes in today's
game will learn how to adjust some won't
some won't survive it
some will suffer because of it but most
will be able to understand that this is
how I have to play the game differently
our reward system was different there
were more toning limbs more guys that
put the ball in play that's the way the
game was played then you have to play in
the era of which you're being rewarded
to do John you're the best enjoy tonight
with with Joe I know I will
I appreciate the car soon well chat soon
all right thanks you bet that's John
Smoltz calling a game for Fox tonight I
with Joe Buck for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app